all right last week down in Florida I
appeared on the pbd podcast hosted by
Patrick Bett David wide-ranging
conversation have received hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of comments about
it we're going to show you the whole
conversation here here's my thought now
that it's been you know a week since the
since the appearance I think it was a
fine experience I did in the moment
struggle with the kind of straw Manning
and misstatement of the things that I
was saying or really things things that
I was not saying but I also think it was
useful to expose that these are
techniques which doesn't even mean that
Patrick was doing it deliberately you
really can shut down a conversation by
just rapidly changing topics misstating
what your your guest is saying and and
sort of like just bogging down the
conversation that being said I do think
I could have been better prepared to try
to retake control of some of those
discussions the entire thing around
taxation I should have had a way
to refocus the conversation in terms
that made more sense rather than just
kind of like continue this bizarre
jumping around stream of Consciousness
that we did on some of the issues of
like International opinion about the
United States
it got so muddled that the conversation
became meaningless and we went around in
circles so I think I have a lot to learn
from the appearance but I think it was
very much worth doing let's check it out
let me know your thoughts uh in a
comment after you watch it
[Music]
look what I become
we'll figure it out by the end of the
show yeah I think
all right so special podcast today we
were hoping to do it in March but we
couldn't but we're able to make your
work today and uh a lot of people online
with the pack you got you got to get
them on Pat you got to get them on it'd
be great be a great conversation finally
we made a make it work newly uh father
of seven months which is congratulations
to you thank you it's great to have
David Pacman on the podcast it's so
great to be here I'm shocked people
wanted me here they really did that I
mean you were getting tagged left and
right that's right we're talking on the
Twitter and yeah anyways we were able to
make it work so how how's everything how
you doing everything's good good yeah
how's it feel being a father it's it's
weird it's like completely different and
kind of everything's the same you know
it's weird and biggest shock I mean like
oh I didn't expect this
um you know I thought maybe like two or
three diapers would be enough for a few
months you need way more than two or
three rookie move now so what's most
expensive cost that you're feeling well
the most expensive one was the night
nurses at the beginning
um because as you know my audience knows
my my girlfriend ended up back in the
hospital after the delivery and it was
me at two weeks and and so I was like we
need night nurses and night nurses you
know are not the cheapest thing wow so
that was the so after that I'm like oh
diapers this is this is great diapers is
cheap yeah night nurses yeah that's
pretty epic yeah wait till uh they turn
one and you find out how much eggs are
gonna cost it's gonna be catastrophic so
hang in there well she's already on eggs
you know so it's uh yeah by the way
public PSA I'm also looking for some
night nurses out there I don't have any
kids but if some night nurses just want
to come in
you're looking for nice you want to come
in and take care of some things
throughout the night just his
interpretation of night nurses are very
different than David David is not in the
adult and entertainment business David
is not like in you know a player he's
just saying somebody that was helping
him with the kids these are medical
professionals exactly that's a better
way of putting it that's all I'm looking
for as well here gentlemen it's a mouth
to mouth all right stop it let's go okay
so David for the people that don't know
if you can take a quick moment and just
kind of give them your background you've
got a massive YouTube channel your you
got billions of views online you've done
great work you and maybe share with them
what your philosophies are what you
believe in and we'll get started so my
30-second backstory born in Argentina
family moved to the U.S immigrant
learned the language Public School
etc etc all of that different stuff
interested in media interested in
politics and Argentina politics is like
everything everybody's always talking
about politics I'm sure you know in your
background it's similar
um and eventually started this community
Radio Show podcast when I was a doing
undergrad
had the fortune that I could just kind
of try making it a job while a lot of my
you know classmates ended up having to
get real jobs that were not very good
um and it it worked fortunately I think
it was a combination of timing and the
opportunity and the fact that I had a
situation where I could just let's see
if this thing works and I can avoid
having to get a real job
and then it combined with when YouTube
was blowing up and podcasting and all
these things so my show is a it's a
left-wing Progressive call it you know
whatever you want sort of podcast and
I'm sure we'll get into my philosophy
more specifically
um but we are we that's the space I
occupy and we talk news and politics do
interviews I've done over 1500
interviews on the show
um and that's that's the thing now we're
multi-platform YouTube Facebook twitch
podcasts Etc so look my biggest
challenge with you is I think you go a
little overboard when it comes on to
supporting Trump and I think it's
inappropriate I know yeah honestly like
it's a little too much I know people who
are manga people who love him but you
like not like dude yeah I don't know how
did your infatuation with Trump I just
think his hair and his physical prowess
and strength is so incredible his golf
game is unbelievable and I consider golf
a proxy towards basically everything in
life if you're a good golfer the way
Trump is yeah then you're good at every
really I mean that's that's the best
something I say but by the way do you
miss them be honest do I miss them so
that there's a and a crazy question for
you just a crazy question for you like
for me you know how uh CNN ratings just
came out and ratings you know I don't
know what the numbers was we'll get into
it here in a minute uh worse in nine
years I don't know what the numbers were
but if you can pull up the article worse
than nine years right so do you think
like
you sit there and you say like for
comedy yeah like comedians
you know a great comedian maybe can do
make fun of everybody yeah okay Schultz
he can do anybody Chappelle can't do
anybody Rogan these guys can't do
anybody right you know but sometimes
like the market needs a good president
to make fun of yeah right so you know
there's a lot you can do with Biden but
there's a lot more you can do with oh
absolutely and he's he's so funny in
spite of himself yeah and sometimes it's
he'll say one thing like he'll call you
know the the CEO of Lockheed Marilyn
Lockheed but that's not her name her
name is her last name is not the name of
the company that's funny in the moment
Tim Apple Tim apple right there's these
are I said Tim Cook you pretty much said
Tim Apple there's this Arc like for
example where Trump weirdly gets
obsessed with toilets during his during
his 2020 campaign I don't know if you
guys remember this but he would go to
rallies and he would go and they're
they're turning down the flow on my
toilets you're going to have to flush
toilets 10 to 15 times and I'm thinking
what is Trump doing with a toilet where
you need 10 flushes right it's weird but
that's just the first piece so then on
Election night when he talks about how
he really won you know which he lost
um he he says what they were massive
dumps in the middle of the night and
you're like 15 flushes massive dumps and
then later for you later that was good
later you find out he was flushing
documents down the toilet so you're like
going back a year that's the reason the
toilet he was so concerned about toilets
he's flushing documents himself so how
do you handle the whole uh uh you know
but even for yourself as a content
creator do you miss him as a con like
would you selfishly forget about
political of course you don't want him
you would have probably had Bernie over
Biden I would assume maybe somebody else
who would have been your guy if you had
your choice yeah I mean I I think Bernie
is the closest when you look at policy
to me but I've been very critical of the
way Bernie runs his campaign I Bernie
talks about he's a socialist I don't
know I'm not a socialist and I don't
don't actually think Bernie ran on a
socialist platform but we can get to
that but I I've said to my audience
Trump was great for shows like mine
there's no question about it right like
speaking if I was if I was Voting not
for what I think is best for the country
but what's best for me financially of
course Trump was a gold mine there's no
question about it so who who did you
want like if you were to say like today
you have your choice on who can be the
president who would you like
it's the the reason I'm going to answer
the question but the reason that it's a
hard question to answer in that way is
there's policy and there's who could win
who would be good at governing who can
who understands how to make compromise
and sort of how politics is done so I
think there's a ton of really
interesting people that do well in all
of these areas and and I'll give you a
few names and I from this is now for my
audience because if what I'm about to
say they'll say you you're just the
insult in Myspace is you're a lib
meaning I'm not aggressive I'm not left
enough right okay I think folks like
it's it's crazy yeah I think the people
that are striking the right balance
right now between policy and rhetoric
and ability to actually be good
politicians are people like and this is
gonna be crazy okay Gavin Newsom Pete
bootage Stacy Abrams Katie Porter in
California I think these are really
interesting folks who I don't
necessarily agree with them on all
policy but I think they bring a few
things that are important they're
younger right now I think there's a
problem where it's it's sort of like old
guy after old guy after old guy on both
sides we're seeing this to a degree so I
like that I think they bring some
Progressive policies that are
interesting without really being
brandable as being socialists and I
think that that's all really important
right now for the for the left so what
do you like about so okay so let's let's
stay with who we currently have right
now so today Biden yeah what's he doing
good what do you think he's not doing
good okay so if I were to say here are
the things that Biden got done that are
accomplishments that are important and
you know think things that that are
worth doing at a time where I think it
was necessary he did that third covet
stimulus remember Trump did two of them
and Biden Biden did a third one I think
at the time it made sense and he didn't
include as much of this or really any if
I recall the PPP slush fund which was so
fraudulently used and now you know the
IRS is backed up on audits in part
because they're doing PPP fraud
investigation so I like that he didn't
include that I didn't think that that
was necessary inflation reduction act
does a lot of interesting things and
whether or not it quote reduces is
inflation inflation is coming down now
several months in a row I love the
renewable energy stuff that's in there I
drive an electric car I've got the solar
panels I've got you know my gas stove
I'm even going to get rid of I'm ready
I'm ready to get rid of them is that
serious no yeah you're fully committed
it's not a commitment it's the induction
is unbelievable once you actually learn
to use it it's fantastic I was repeating
oh you get the gas stove you can
modulate down to it's beautiful I've now
cooked with induction it's fantastic so
I'm I'm fully I think it's fantastic I
think encouraging that we're not Banning
gas stoves of course I'm exaggerating I
think that that's really great
um I think getting getting out of
Afghanistan I think was the absolute
right decision many criticisms of the
chaos that unfolded when Trump was asked
how would you have done it differently
he didn't actually have any answer it
was Trump's plan to get out that Biden
did a few months later because Trump
never got to it for whatever reason I
think that was the right decision it was
going nowhere 20 years there Etc
um on student loan forgiveness I don't
know what's going to happen eventually
I'm not a forgive all student loans guy
some in my audience are like David all
loans should be forgiven it's like no I
don't think so I don't think that makes
sense but we've had programs like if
you're a doctor and you work in an
underserved Community long enough you
qualify to get those loans forgiven I
think certain programs like that make a
lot of sense so I think that that's a
good thing and quite frankly and this is
where you know the the Trump people
email me and they get very mad if not my
opinion if we go by Gallup opinion
survey what other countries think of the
US opinion of the U.S has dramatically
improved since Biden replaced Trump I
think that matters I I'm not an
isolationist so I think it's important
that other countries respect the office
of the presidency and under trump it was
a joke you know literally laughed at at
the UN goes to India mispronounces 10
Indian names and the crowd is just
leaving it it was a humiliation
everywhere he went so I think that's a
great it's like a soft thing that I
think is really good so the the fact
that we're no longer feared is a good
thing I don't know where you're getting
that we are no longer fear so you think
people fear Biden what I'm asking you is
where what data do you have that we are
no longer well that's not it that's what
data is not uh any data to give I mean
how do you know what it is well no but
but during bite during Biden is when
Russia felt comfortable bullying Ukraine
during Biden is uh even if you look at
Afghanistan on the way we left people on
the left we're not happy by the way we
left Afghanistan even 82 billion now I
can give you a lot of different names
like the CIA who's the CIA guy that we
had here who was on uh
with a z what's his name
um Matt Zeller Matt Zeller CI agent who
was on MSNBC he called him out he was on
MSNBC with uh but that's one person
right but there's a lot of them though
if I actually said if I actually pull it
up and if I if I do the Google search on
it I'll find plenty of names from their
own side let's do it that's fine but I
think one important thing to back up is
you first kind of gave me what's not
really a very fair question you go are
you not worried that the US is no longer
fear so you're saying they they don't
fear but hold on let me finish let me
finish my response okay you first
presented to me and these are a lot of
conversations go like this you present
to me is it not a concern to me that the
U.S is no longer feared and I said well
where are you getting that where's the
data you go out there is no data so
where let's first start with no what I
said is this that's not the fee I didn't
say there's no data you can't you can't
pull data meaning you can't find data on
fear and how do you know that that fear
is action fear is action did during uh
did during Trump Russia attack Ukraine
no that's that what happened with
Palestine and Israel
what happened yeah what happened they
came together after 20 some years what
what are you talking about when you say
what are you talking about
has there been any progress on peace
very limited did moving the cat did move
it wasn't the capital Did moving the
embassy Embassy let me ask the question
did moving the embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem get us closer to peace or did
it get us further further away do either
of you guys know I don't know if you've
studied this issue there's arguments on
both end but it has not led to peace and
prosperity in Palestine correct did
Trump promise this this very critical
clear question did Trump promise that
Jared Kushner would solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict during the
first term yes nobody promise it I don't
know if he promised it or promises made
Promises Kept he was assigned to that
Duty and did it happen
did what happened did Jared negotiate no
but I don't think anybody believed that
peace was happening so it's okay for him
to make promises but make the make the
argument go back to the argument about
the fact that America on all polls today
is would you say liked what was the word
you used so I I think the really
important thing when we talk about this
is we talk about what we can measure so
the Gallup
polling that has been done so you trust
polls oh come on but that's where we're
going though there are there are lots
because I trust certain polls too but
I'm saying so you trust polls if you say
do I trust a Rasmussen Republican
primary poll 18 months before an
election I would say that's a that's not
very valuable I don't think that's
valuable the Gallup public opinion
sentiment poll that has been done over
many many presidents in the same way I
think that that's a pretty good poll
just to give a sense of how the world
feels about the American president I
have no reason to distrust that there
are other polls where I would have a
specific reason to distrust but we're
kind of going like 10 10 tangents here I
think if we want to talk about
am I upset that the U.S isn't feared
since you brought that question forward
the appropriate thing would be for you
to give me the data but no go go back to
what you said you said U.S is what you
said you like the fact that U.S has
liked more today under Biden no I didn't
use that term what was the term you used
if you don't believe it again on average
yeah countries respect the us more now
that Biden is President you value that I
think it's important because I and I can
I tell you why sure I think it's
important because between trade and
globalization and problems we deal with
that don't respect the borders of
countries it's important to be again
it's not about liked it's not about it's
to be respected globally I do think that
that actually so so why do you think
they didn't like or respect Trump let's
see what you're going to say with that
why do you think tell me the guy's a
joke he is yeah okay tell us why and
bike man Biden's not a joke we can talk
about Bible because Biden's like the
[Music]
but I think it's important to say are we
talking about Trump or are we talking
about Biden no no talk about identify
talk about them one at a time stay on
Trump okay stay on Trump when he say
he's a joke tell us why you think he's a
joke
um
promises made that were not kept that he
told us he was going to achieve for us
let's look at some of them I'm going to
get rid of Obamacare and replace it with
his word a beautiful replacement where
everyone will have care and it's going
to be affordable okay
just flat out didn't happen the one
proposal that Republicans made would
have led to 24 to 32 million people
losing health care I consider that a
failure I don't think Obamacare is
perfect but it's better than the think
Trump think Trump said he was going to
bring us that was that was just a
failure two build a wall across the
entire U.S Mexico border which Mexico is
going to pay for
it's not even worth having a conver I
mean just a joke of course of course
completely didn't happen solve the
israeli-palestinian conflict no progress
made in fact to be honest and this is
you know if we want to delve into that
moving the embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem got us further from that
because it's seen as a sort of um a
taunting measure if you understand the
internal politics of what's what's going
on there
um was going to you know the made some
space travel promises I mean we could I
can't think of promises he made that he
did keep other than
um I guess the the he was going to do
tax reform and he did tax reform so as a
policy matter a complete and total
failure I do think maybe the first step
act on Criminal Justice Reform did some
good things I'm I'm sort of glad to give
him credit on that
um but so you know on policy failure and
then you know on rhetoric we could spend
three hours just looking at quotes so
I'm curious to see exactly how you think
now yeah if if covet doesn't happen does
he get reelected yes why well because
his followers don't care about policy I
interview them all the time and I say
followers don't care about power they
don't care about achievements they care
about Hillary bad Hillary Marxist
Hillary socialist you think Hillary's
good
did I say that no I'm asking you oh no
uh I don't think Hillary was a good
candidate and she's she's to my right
um no I don't think Hillary's good but I
thought she was better than Trump she's
to your right she's to my right yeah
Hillary is a very moderate conservative
Democrat yeah your world yeah yeah
good I mean give me a left-wing Hillary
policy like a really left-wing Hillary
policy
I couldn't tell you but that's I'm not
there is none but that's not the point
where you're saying you would much
rather have a Hillary than a trump I
would rather okay so go back much rather
I don't know so so go back to he gets
reelected why because his uh uh voters
could care less about policies that's
what you're saying fine no problem so
but we both know that it's not the right
that's elected him and it's not the left
that'll like whoever on the left it's
whoever's in the middle that's the a to
12 that kind of says you know what I'm
gonna go this side you know this time
around or versus more people come out
for you know their candidate meaning a
lot of people would come out for Obama
okay so explain yourself the the what
what it actually more depends on is who
chooses to go out and vote it's less
about you know there's there's often
this idea in politics and there's lots
of people who are really good on this
issue that you could talk to Rachel
bidikoffer and even Frank Luntz even
though he's partisan I think he would
concede this as well he's a poster yes
the idea of the Swing independent voter
that sometimes on unpreced elections
will vote for a Republican and sometimes
a Democrat very very small percentage of
people more common is that a candidate
either activates people to vote or those
same people just stay home in the U.S we
have an embarrassingly low voter voter
turnout it's between usually usually 52
and 60 percent I think so almost half
the electorate isn't even voting it's
less about people who vote one way and
then another way it's more about people
who say I'm just going to stay home
versus I'm going to go out and vote if
they vote it's clear so you're saying
that the middle voter doesn't matter at
all no I didn't say that so what are you
saying I said they matter much less than
who who is partisan chooses to vote but
it's fair to say that okay if if he
continues so if he continues
and there's no covid he would get
re-elected do you think the let's
specifically Target the middle forget
the people on the side that would show
up well why that's that's the question I
want to do with you right now so if we
if we specifically focus on the Middle
with the middle the independent the
Libertarians would they have chosen to
stick with Trump or would most have
wanted to replace him with somebody else
it's a polling question I don't know the
data well you're the pole guys so I'm
asking you I don't have the data okay
I'd be curious to know so you're but
you're also correcting me to say that's
not true that's the middle and the
Independence that that didn't elect them
you're saying it's who showed up that
elected him as a general concept right
elections swing less based on
Independence who sometimes vote
Republican and Democrat that's a small
factor a bigger factor is are voters
activated by their candidate or are they
deactivated where they go I don't like
this person but I'm definitely not
voting for that one I'll stay home so
isn't it a bit of both though it's a bit
of both because
we've seen countless stories about I
voted for Obama I'm not racist I voted
for Obama what are you talking about I
voted for Bush then I voted for Obama
and then Trump showed up he made some
promises he he was in the midwest he was
he was he was he was out there he was
reaching out touch your hands Hillary
was too busy in New Mexico and Arizona I
decided to vote for Trump and I was sort
of done with Trump now I'm back on Biden
yeah we see so many stories like that
that's these Independence that's an
anecdote and so I think anecdotes are
fine but one of the things that um is
important is to zoom out from anecdotes
and to look at the broader data and the
other thing that's important is a lot of
that cross-voting it cancels each other
out because you see roughly the same
amount from one side versus the other
and what what I mean by that is there
was if you look at the crossover in 2016
the number of Democrats who decided to
vote Trump in 2016 was very similar to
vote McCain in 2008 so it it's it's it's
a roughly predictable number you're
talking about Democrats who have
switched over just there's legitimate
Independence I'm giving you just one
example of this people who go either way
or whatever it's it's relatively stable
and predictable so it's rarely A
Difference Maker that that's my only
point and we can anecdotes all day you
know Jim Bob's wife decided to vote
Hillary or what yeah it's that totally
fine but let's do data because you're a
data guys so if you're a data guy tell
us when you're saying it's not
necessarily that the middle one would
have had Trump yeah would he have needed
the middle to get reelected in 2024 in
he would have needed roughly the same
percentage that Republicans tend to need
Trump suffered because they're they're
he on on the covet thing would he have
gotten reelected it's not only if covet
didn't happen Trump probably would have
gotten reelected I think if when kovitz
started instead of trump saying we have
15 cases soon going to be zero do flu
vaccines work on covid what about bleach
injections all that stuff if instead of
that Trump said hey you know what we're
the United States we're going to deal
with this better than anybody else we're
making Maga masks and by the way 50
cents on every dollar will go you know
his his normal fundraising scams right
do the scams but do the Maga masks and
if he said we're going to be absolutely
the best on this thing he wins we saw it
in New Zealand we saw it in other places
it was a missed opportunity now I think
it was just a miscalculation in the
sense that somewhere Trump probably
thought it was really going to go away I
don't know who was around him I don't
know who's by Easter of 2020 right I
mean okay so I think Trump even if he
had just done that and because why would
he have why why would the why would the
Independents the ones in the middle who
are uh let's just say slightly more
reasonable and they're willing to say
you know I don't like this guy on the
left I'm gonna vote right I don't like
this guy on the right I'm gonna vote
left yeah why would they have still
chosen Trump over Biden we're now I have
no idea you'd have to talk to them I
just don't know but you're given you're
given your arguments and so your
arguments you're given is you're talking
about uh uh polls like Biden because
America is more respected under Biden
than Trump okay so that has nothing to
do with American voters we're talking
about people in other countries I
totally get it but but when you're when
you say something like that the voter
says oh wow America the world respects
Biden more than they respect Trump sure
okay somebody may say well maybe because
you know anybody who was an enemy of
America hated Trump because Trump would
you know deal more directly with them
than Biden would Biden you can't
necessarily see him you know he doesn't
look like a leader he's not an
obama-esque he's not a Clinton guy Biden
doesn't come across as a strong leader
but you're saying he's more respected
than Trump great no problem okay so then
I go and I ask you a question and I say
if Kobe doesn't happen does he get
reelected yes why you say because more
people show up this whole you know this
whole narrative about the fact that you
need the middle voter to Tipton that's
not true it's how many people show up
and it's his people because his people
don't care if he gets anything done
that's what you said that was your
narrative right that's what you said
those were your words some of those
words mirror the things that I said yes
okay so so it activates which means uh
so Trump's voters so give me when you
say I speak to a lot of these Trump
voters there's obviously a lot of
animosity in you you have a lot of
resent more animosity towards them I
don't know why but you seem angry and
obsessed towards Trump I mean your
comments like you know towards Trump is
Boom you know voters or this voters or
that well to you what problem maybe I
have to I have to interrupt that but I
get that so what is the what is and you
can answer all those questions and I'll
give you your time I'm not remembering
all of them but I'll try to write what
is the DNA of a typical Mega voter in
your eyes there there's not any typical
DNA I think there's basically three
primary categories of people that vote
for republicans and Trump introduced a
fourth fair to introduce these four
categories break it down for us for us
that you know we don't have your
intelligence well it's not about
intelligence and I don't know if you're
being sarcastic it's not about
intelligence this is your world okay so
this is your world so so you know tell
us what you think about the three and
the fourth I with your intelligence
imagine what you could do if you looked
up the things I look up that's really
the incredible okay no so in all
seriousness four basic groups pre-trump
you had three groups you had sort of
pro-business low tax uh right Wingers
people like Mitt Romney basically they
are I mean Romney maybe isn't a little
bit of an exception because there's a
Mormon he has some socially conservative
views but you've got like your Romney
type who's concerned with let's not over
regulate businesses let's not have taxes
that are too high let's create a good
business environment as governor of
Massachusetts that was sort of uh his
his idea and that's a very blue State
and he did well so you've got like your
Romney type traditional low tax limited
government yeah not Republic uh not
extreme millionaire not extreme rights
and social issues type people
particularly homophobic for example or
you know okay then you've got your more
libertarian-minded people I found it
interesting when you said you're
independent and Libertarians in the U.S
Libertarians are mostly right-wing and
they mostly vote for Republicans so then
you've got your very libertarian-minded
people uh who whose focus is that we
want just as much as much freedom to do
as much stuff as possible it often
includes freedom to discriminate if I
don't want to do you know like a gay
wedding cake that that you've got that
group you then have Evangelical and
religious voters whose primary things
are less economic what was your second
one second one is libertarian
libertarian okay third you've got your
Evangelical the Mike Pence vote if you
will more than Mike Pence vote people
for whom abortion and gay marriage and
more recently you know trans stuff
that's really the most important they'll
go with the economic stuff even though
it's actually often not good for them
and you started to see this under Reagan
a lot where these religious voters they
went with Reagan even though
economically it wasn't the best thing
for them those are typically the three
groups you hear you hear the common term
they're voting against their interests
because they have social uh ideology
someday gravitate towards so you've got
those three groups Trump had all all of
that the early Ted Cruz support in 2016
is that third group that Evangelical
that eventually went to Trump trump
coalesced these groups because they
really weren't going to vote for Hillary
the fourth group which Trump kind of
created is people who were not at all
engaged with politics before
they didn't pay attention they knew
Trump is a celebrity they didn't really
have a political identity they were
disaffected they weren't really
participating before so four is his
personalities what you're saying or yeah
they got brought in specifically he
introduced that that's been around for a
while though he introduced what you're
saying he Trump introduced the fourth
you said typically it's three oh yeah
but Trump introduced the fourth or Trump
has the fourth Trump is activated
activated this fourth group which was
people who were not in any of those
three categories I mentioned and got
engaged in politics for the first time
because they heard Trump say something
that they liked give some examples of
those type of are you talking about West
Virginia coal miners or people in the
Deep Red South it's there they were from
all over but it was people who like that
Trump was going to fix trade with China
A lot of them didn't really know what
that meant but it sounded pretty good
maybe the person had lost a job they
came to believe it's it's because of
China that I lost my job that sounds
good or people who are on immigration
they're like the wall of course you and
I know you're never building a wall
never mind Mexico is going to pay for it
but there were people who like the idea
never were in politics like no it sounds
good I'm voting for Trump so he brought
in this fourth group
okay so so the fourth group to be exact
it's his personality that people were
turned on by the way he was could be
personality but it could be that there
was one thing he said so so let me ask
the question is there something wrong
with that I'm curious are you going to a
place where this there's something wrong
with that or no it's not about right or
wrong it's a question of whether any of
us think that the
policy motivations for any of those
groups aligned with ours somebody may
say there's a lot of people that showed
up for Obama just because he was black
sure they can say that I don't know I
mean I don't know
you don't think it's true of course in a
country of 330 million people there are
going to be some but you said you don't
know if it's true it's like what do you
mean you don't know if it's true I don't
have any you don't have any data you
want to get data to say people showed up
that they just because they're black
there's exit polling on most of these
issues we might be able to find it right
now you know no it's it's uh you know
it's fair to say people voted for me I
mean I cannot even tell you how many
people
uh uh I know Republicans who were voting
for uh Obama in the insurance industry
just because like listen man the first
time this guy talks like MLK you know he
sounds reasonable I'm gonna vote for the
guy there's a lot of people that came
out with him so somebody may say well
you know the reason why Obama got
elected because he's got the three
difficult things when he talks to the
democrata but the fourth thing is he was
black okay and are you gonna say what I
would say yeah I'm sure that there's a
portion of people who vote so so so
you're saying the DNA of a trump Mega
voter
who looks past policies so you're saying
on the three policies he didn't check
off the three policies here the three
points you're saying that
I I'm saying he didn't build the wall or
I mean let me take a step back with you
so I'm asking a question and I said so
tell me if you're saying he's going to
get reelected without covet you're
saying he would have gone reelected I
think he would have perfect and then you
said your words you said something in
the context of you know because I think
the Maga voter is not about policies
that's what you said a lot of that
fourth group yes is not about
overarching accomplishments or like I'll
give you an example of what I'm talking
about and maybe it'll help to distill it
I got a call at some point during the
first term of trump from a guy who said
I'm voting for this guy this guy is just
the best and I said oh okay what do you
care about what how are you evaluating
his performance to decide if you're
going to vote for him in 2020. like how
do you I'm curious how do you decide he
said well I care about the wall so he's
he's got to Build That Wall I said
perfect if he doesn't build the wall are
you still going to vote for him and he
says well yeah I'm not going to vote for
a Democrat so I said oh so it doesn't
act actually matter if he builds the
wall same with you as well though
there's no way you're voting for a
republican either would you vote for a
Republican sure yeah I mean if you ever
voted for Republican president a
represent no I mean okay elections yeah
but hold on a second but you're 40 years
old you're you're 1984 so I'm 38. please
84 38 years old 30 years still you've
had plenty of Elections let's back up
for a second do you there's two
questions would I and have I I've only
voted in a few presidential election
we've had plenty of chances well but who
would I voted for I was going to vote
for George W Bush in 2004 no but it
doesn't matter the point is when you're
calling that guy out you're the same as
that guy no I'm not okay so tell me
you're Republican you'd vote for you're
I don't I think you're missing the
picture what is it the point is
he made a claim that he was going to
make a vote depending on policy and when
I then said so if the policy fails
you'll vote for someone else and he said
no actually the policy doesn't matter
that's the difference I'm not making
that claim yeah okay it's a completely
different thing I mean the same can be
said to to uh to take one example of a
story of a person who sounds like an
idiot to say that and then categorize
everybody and from this selective
hearing to say that's not what I'm doing
that's that's selective for you well you
are kind of doing that you're saying
here's a republican voter who you ask or
why are you thinking about voting for
Trump oh because he's building the wall
then he said if he doesn't build a wall
well I would never vote for a Democrat
well do you care if the wall never gets
built no I don't care I'm on vote for
him anyways well that's that's it that's
that doesn't sound like a reasonable
voter to me though that's right he's not
a reasonable well the reasonable voters
to me was also if if you were to ask the
average person who voted for Biden sure
they didn't vote for Biden okay they
voted against Trump okay do you disagree
I'd have to look at exit polls okay so
is that is that where you go to for
something like or a guy who if this is
your space yeah what's your podcast
about
what is it about what's your show about
news in politics you should know this
stuff you're the expert I probably
should remember that offhand how do you
find it right now but this is your world
like if you ask me questions on business
I'm going to say let me give you my
feedback on what I think about business
yeah you invite me on your podcast hey
Pat I want to talk about about business
let's do that I have no problem with it
to do no do that part but what I'm
saying to you is if you're coming here
saying what you're saying sure and then
I ask you a simple question of so the
same thing can be said about people that
voted for Biden yeah I'm stupid I'm
gonna vote for anybody dude nobody would
show up when Biden would speak did you
not see his tour when he was going
campaigning Patrick you're not really
doing this are you tell them you're
doing this I'm actually curious where
you're going to go now Simon wasn't even
doing events where I mean this is the
Biden one from the basement there yeah I
have a counter to this entire and I want
to just be really clear
I don't really care about defending
Biden in any particular sense I just
think he was the better option than
Trump I I feel like I'm being framed as
this Biden lover who's going to defend
everything I'm not doing that you may be
thinking I'm not doing that to you what
I'm asking what I want to say about this
can you pull up Biden's rallies when he
was running for president go ahead let's
see the pictures but go ahead Biden
didn't do a campaign the way Trump did
it and the funniest thing to me neither
has anybody done a like the way Biden's
done it he hit well let but hold the
guys we're this was during covid though
yes let's back up for a second look how
beautiful that is well that's these are
because
this is really the you're telling me
you're you've seen silly here's what I'm
willing to do here's what I'm willing to
do please I'm willing to give him yeah a
million dollars of my own money right
now to go try to fill up an arena for
what what's the point oh no to show that
nobody is inspired by this guy this is
silly
see what silly is what silly is for you
to assume people voted for Biden they
voted against Trump is what they did no
they did yeah sure yeah but what you
just said I said percentages but it's
your world though this is like if you're
gonna if you're gonna sit here and sell
you know talk about how uh how bad the
the Trump voter is and you let me tell
you you know it's these people all they
care about is is personality outside of
the taxes and all this other stuff and
then I ask you a question I say so why
do people vote for Biden many of them
vote on because they just didn't want
Trump yeah I don't know the numbers on
that you should okay you should know
those numbers what I just don't know
that offhand I mean it's we can look it
up it's why why do I need to memorize
can I make a quick Point can I just get
because there's one thing I want to say
here go ahead this entire Biden hid
stuff it's so it's such a self hit or
hit hid in his basement yeah because
when you talk about oh the he said
though he hit a lot of times but
okay
if I were on the right I would stop
saying that because it's embarrassing to
Trump that he lost to a guy who hid in
his basement that's not that's the
that's the crazy you're president your
guy Joe Biden is the greatest hide and
go seek champion of all time
is he not he's not your president he's
my president okay he's our president but
he's your guy he's the guy you're
defending you're defending him right now
to say only that he's better than Trump
because you're making me do this the
only reason that there's no way in a
even the Liberals today are not saying
he's better than uh uh Trump in
executing or taking action or doing
anything let's find out the only the
only credit well at this point you've
lost credibility to talk about polls
because you don't even know what you're
talking about when you're saying well I
don't know I don't know if the people
were voting against Trump let's find the
poll so if you if you can't agree to
that I don't know how many of course
they were it's not just how many any
it's if you go on look at any of these
uh uh people who were doing uh uh what
do you call a street to when they're
going talking to people interviews yeah
it's like hey so tell me who would you
vote here Trump's the worst I would
never vote for him people didn't want to
vote for this guy because because 99 of
the media everybody was sitting there
bashing them not non-stop that just by
the way same thing's gonna happen with
the santis yeah same thing happened with
bush the only Republicans Democrats like
is ex-presidents who are now painters
that's the only Republicans Democrats
like because they're no no longer a
threat Trump's a big threat so for for
for you to say well we now have respect
around the world yeah I don't even know
if I want that I think if there's an
element of competition because I I think
if China has to choose between Trump or
Biden
and China would rather have Biden that's
probably not a good sign for me okay is
it a good sign if Russia wants Trump I
mean this is kind of a silly game right
no but but Russia is not our number one
enemy Russia doesn't control 80 of chips
Russia is not as powerful as people
think they are they have a lot of nukes
they lead the world totally get it but
we're seeing right now what's happening
to Russia Russia is more they're
powerful you got to put them up there
they're strong
but China is really really strong in
experience China hates America China
doesn't uh they've publicly announced
what they're going to be doing you know
there's a very big difference between
China and Russia and by the way I'm not
sitting here telling you we got to be
best friends with Russia but if China
likes a president over another one that
is a red flag for me yeah it's not rare
as a view on the American right that is
generally who cares what other countries
think I would almost rather they hate us
that's really common I didn't say that
no no I'm not that's what you were
saying I want to see a poll on that do
you have a poll on that not offhand then
why do you have a poll give me a poll
Patrick but no go give me a poll because
you're that's an anecdote now we can use
this but no you're up in your
conversation but you're not doing that
but that's what you're doing it
longer you're the political expert on
that oh come on you're the political
expert what you just no you're being
silly so I'm giving you exactly what
you've been doing for the first 30
minutes now it officially bothers you no
no it doesn't bother me but I think it's
silly I think we don't get anywhere but
wait a minute but what you're saying is
that if the argument you give us said
show me a poll yeah show it to me you
can't do it there's a difference between
between saying that there's a specific
opinion among voters that they were
motivated by a particular reason you
have polling on that we just have to
find it you're like you're like you like
to use that but not when it works
against you yeah I didn't say hate I'm
not a hate guy if I was a hate guy you
wouldn't be here today I didn't say that
no you no you said most Republicans
would prefer if uh uh other countries
hated us you're putting you're assuming
I didn't say most run it back wait you
didn't say what I didn't say most you
said there is a contingent on the right
right that actually is emboldened by if
they how small of a community is that
don't know
so you're going to take the exception
are you going to make that argument oh
my God yeah Patrick
I don't I'm I'm I'm I'm for clumped yeah
um you and I both you and Linda Richmond
I um
I we've it just we're going tangent
tangent tangent where we can't really
drill down on any one issue I'm saying
to you hate is not if I had hate I would
have not had you on I didn't I describe
that word to you you you said I said
fear
I said fear earlier in the show no no
what I mean is I if if China
prefers any president yeah for example
if McConnell is going to be president
and China wants McConnell over
let's pick a uh I don't know over Tulsi
okay I'm not I'm not McConnell okay if
China wants uh uh uh pick a uh what it
what is her name Liz Cheney if China was
Liz Cheney over
mm-hmm
I would be hesitant there okay because
who is the number one enemy
who is the number one enemy actually
curious what you're going to think about
that I don't know this is the part that
I'm not asking polls I don't know about
the term enemy I mean I think in terms
of adversary I think it's I think it's
Russia and China differently in
different ways as you talked about we
depend way more on China for goods that
we enjoy being cheap because they're
made in China rather than here I agree
that confers huge economic power China
Russia in a different way yes it's the
nukes yes it's the more unstable leader
it's also alliances with countries where
Russia's involvement can goad or pull
the United States in in ways that are
both resource intensive and politically
disadvantageous so I think they are
those are the two countries
I mean there's there's the Afghanistan
situation
um you could argue Russia I mean with
with Venezuela there's there's issues
there that are more economic relating to
oil which we've talked about
um it's less about products and it's
less about supply chain with Russia
although with energy Russia is a factor
um but I think those are our two biggest
adversaries I don't know if the right
term is enemy I'm open to exploring
whether that's the right term certainly
adversary is the right term I I think
I'm on the same page with you on whether
it's adversary or enemy you know uh keep
in mind I've never taken anything past
ESL in my English so my the word enemy
and adversary may have the same meaning
to me maybe a different meaning for you
fair its opposition is how I see it uh
but I agree but but the part for me is
if a country yeah is overly comfortable
with one and is afraid of imposing pain
on them and kind of backs off a little
bit I want to know a little bit more do
you apply that to every country or only
the countries you're concerned about
like China and what I mean by that is
I'll give you I know what you're going
to go to Russia no no Trump no no no
forget about that yeah I'm just saying
if Denmark prefers Liz Cheney over Pete
butterjudge does that influence your
thinking not necessarily okay fair so
the so what I'm getting at is you're
concerned not in general with the
opinion no I can I'm saying my domain is
main enemies Denmark is not somebody we
don't wake up in the morning worry about
what denma that's why I asked the
question yeah and Denmark has never
publicly said by 2025 we're going to be
bigger than America and we're going to
do this they've never said that there's
only a few countries that have said that
that's not one of them so it would be
fair then just to say your concern is
not gen so when I say hey you know what
Spain Portugal Italy France UK Argentina
Tina Chile Colombia you know I give you
this they respect Biden more than Trump
that would not be a concern to you
because they aren't the adversaries
you're concerned um no uh uh I'm curious
where you're going with this no nowhere
I'm just
I have no hidden agenda all I'm saying
is this here's what I'm saying let's
just say for example let's say
I don't know
um
a uh SPF same bank Manfred yep if he got
up on the pulpit and for 30 minutes said
great things about you
and then you got up and said 30 minutes
good things about him I'm a little
worried about you okay so I sit there
and I'm saying interesting I get the
concept yeah yeah that's all I'm saying
too okay but it only applies because
it's Sam bankman freed right of course
if you know Kelly who brought me in here
said great things about me that you
would have different opinions she's not
an enemy she's not an adversary correct
yeah yeah okay that's fair so really
there's this small list of countries
where you would say their opinion is a
concern I'm actually really curious
where you're going though just to say
it's not you you acted as though the
general reality no no no I'm not I'm not
I'm not in a uh uh I'm not sitting here
putting everybody I'm telling you top
enemies okay so who's the third who
concerns you the most at third spot I'm
not sure um I mean you could make the
case that you know there's a there's a
view that it would be one of the
so-called Socialist Communist Nations
like North Korea uh people talk about
you know among the American right
there's big concern about Cuba and
Venice I don't really share that concern
I'm not a supporter of either of those
regimes to be clear and I'm glad to talk
about that but I don't really share that
concern I think third actually is more
more difficult to say Iran
yeah Iran Iran is a concern
um not economically
um but it's basically all focused around
nuclear weapons and the possibility of
seeding Terror
um so that's a very different situation
than Russia and very different situation
than than China with third it really
depends on the politics of the person
that you ask and I kind of keep an open
mind on that David why are you not a
socialist
um why am I not a socialist well you say
you're not a soul unless if you are no
no no no okay so tell us why are you not
a socialist I'm not a socialist because
I grew up in Argentina right okay well I
was I was five when I moved to the US
yeah but but I mean like uh some of your
family their their supporters of
socialist like who your mom is not a
your mom supports Socialism or no no
where did I get that there's an article
that says about your mom supports
socialism oh oh you that may so okay in
Argentina yeah in the 60s when my mom
when my parents were kids among the
Jewish Community there were Lefty
socialist Jewish groups they were sort
of like nominally socialist and they
were cultural and Etc and my mom
certainly was part of that when she was
12. uh and 14 but no my mom my parents
that doesn't mean anything because my
mom's a communist yeah yeah no I'm sorry
I'm just curious of where that came from
why why are you not a socialist I think
that the market is a fine way to direct
resources in the vast majority of areas
whether it's sneakers or automobiles or
cell phones I think that that's
absolutely a fine way to direct
resources I see it as an authoritarian
imposition for a government to come to a
business owner like you or like me and
say you must socialize the ownership of
this company and I I'm against that I
don't see any reason for that I don't
see a legal basis and I don't see a
moral basis for it what I am okay with
as a capitalist right so and I know I
saw your conversation with my friend
Kyle Kolinski and it seemed like you
guys were talking past each other a
little bit on social democracy versus
socialism or whatever
I consider myself a Social Democrat sort
of in the mold of Denmark Sweden etc
those are capitalist countries that have
decided to socialize a couple more
things than we've socialized in the
United States that's really the
difference and and it's capitalism it's
a form of capitalism capitalism to make
the money socialism to spend the money
in a lot of these countries uh no I mean
I think that's a it's a that's a common
talking point but maybe to like uh
distill it in a way are we all okay with
socializing the military are you cool
with that like in other words we use
taxes so then let me let me ask a
question a different way so it's it's
funny to me just the way a lot of people
on the other side are funny to you when
somebody says I'm not a socialist but
then they defend socialism and go
straight to military on how much it
costs and how much money spent that's
not the direction but I'm just saying
but no but it's not fair to interrupt
something go ahead rebuttal go ahead I'm
not doing go ahead okay are you okay
socializing the military in the sense
that we have one military run by the
government our taxes pay into it and
it's centralized and that's the military
there aren't a bunch of different
there's not you know Patrick's military
and if you want to pay taxes there and
that military might have different goals
than the military in Texas that would be
crazy right we socialize the military we
have everybody pays their taxes we have
a federal military Fair
keep going do we have that
keep going
we we can't make progress unless we
establish but I'm curious to know where
you're going with this well but because
you said that's not the argument you're
making I'm curious I know where you're
going the argument I was going to make
was not that we spend too much on the
middle okay so I'm curious what you're
going to say are you okay with the
military being organized the way it is
we pay taxes and then the military has
centralized command and that's the way
it's organized is that okay with you at
the federal level that's the current
system that we have here and does it
bother you or is that okay does it
bother me that we have a uh I don't even
think we have at this point but we can
have a strong military that
events future worse for somebody who
lived in Iran and went through War for
10 years with Iraq and experienced all
that yeah I'd like us to have a strong
military okay and you're okay with it
being run the way it's run we pay tax I
don't think we're running it well right
now so I don't know what you mean by
that but I'm not happy with the way we
run it today I these aren't I these
aren't trick questions I'm sure there's
no words let me give a different example
are you okay with the fact that the fire
department is socialized usually at the
municipality you're okay okay are you
okay because because it's Community
because it's where you live yes are you
okay with the FAA being socialized in
the sense that the the traffic air
traffic control is run by the FAA there
aren't all these different air traffic
controls where here's a couple airlines
that use one and then here's a couple
airlines that use another we have the
FAA they run ATC this is what keeps
planes from running into each other our
taxes go into it it's socialized is that
okay with you
socialize means we are Distributing the
cost among the people and giving
centralized control to that entity is it
okay am I am I willing to spend a
portion of my taxes not my question for
that yes okay the difference between
where I think you are politically and
someone like me is I'm okay socializing
a couple more things okay so it's really
when where these conversations go off
the rail with allegations of socialism
and and whatever
you're you've just said you're okay
socializing a number of things I
mentioned and there's more right we
could say are you okay with like the VA
that's a socialized medicine I don't
know if you're okay with the VA maybe
you are maybe you're not you and I agree
on socializing a whole bunch of stuff I
want to socialize a couple more and
otherwise everything's the same I don't
know that that makes me socially let me
let me ask you a question David so uh
out of every dollar you make what are
you comfortable being taxed on like
being taken away it depends what I get
for that can I give an example sure okay
my willingness to be taxed would be
greater if for example my or my
daughter's college education were paid
for by those taxes so in a vacuum it's
really hard to answer that question
because it depends what we get okay so
let me add let me let me continue with
you sure please so uh who do you think
makes better decision for your daughter
you or the government what kinds of
decisions School
what what kind like college just say if
you if you pay me I'm the government but
I'll choose which school she can go to
versus you don't pay me the government
you take that responsibility and you get
to choose to send your daughter to what
school she wants to go to what do you
mean the government chooses but I'm
giving you those Choice those options so
meaning the government says these are
the schools that will pay the tuition
for okay you're talking college and
university I'm talking College okay okay
yeah so I'm assuming that's what you're
talking about you're talking about I
didn't I didn't know which direction you
were going yeah but but so so okay so
but go back to when I asked you the
question I asked the question I said so
what percentage of your
dollar are you willing to be taxed on
yeah not taxed on just taxed
um and you said it depends on what
happens with uh what I'm paying for
right kind of what you said okay so do
you think
um
I mean is that is that logical do you
agree with that at least in principle do
you well well I think I think you have a
good brain
in a good mind to make better decisions
on what to do with your money than the
government can no that but as before we
go into the specific education yeah
because I'm trying to find points of
agreement here because I actually don't
think we're really that far apart on a
lot of these issues are you of the
mindset that just hypothetically are you
okay paying more in taxes if the taxes
include fire police roads bridges are
you generally just have you have you
ever lend anybody money yes but you're
not answering my question but I'm an
answer too this is my way of answering
you have your way of answering I'm gonna
answer it the way I'm answering so have
you ever uh uh lent
um the same person have you ever lent
money to somebody a good amount and they
never paid you back fortunately not okay
yeah cool well guess what yeah
I feel the same way you do about giving
money to the government because they
haven't had a good track record of doing
right things with my money no it sounds
like you're saying the opposite I think
I have not had an experience well you're
wiser good for you that you haven't had
that experience because it sucks but
here's the part uh have you ever lent
your car to somebody and it didn't work
out for you no never happened to you no
I have leases and I just tell them
listen I'm the only person who can drive
I don't even know if that's true my
insurance ever have allowed somebody to
borrow anything from you yeah have you
yes okay give me an idea something
anything something like that they broke
or something like whatever you you lend
somebody oh I'm trying to remember and
people don't really ask me for stuff
very often like this is a serious
question here man like the world is
relying on you giving the right answer
what have I I mean maybe when I was like
14 I lent somebody a Discman and they
did are you a video game guy are you a
gamer not really
so what do you do for fun bike read
travel you ever lent a bike to somebody
God no So you you're you're you may not
be no I've left the bike no I've learned
a bike okay so have you ever lent a bike
to somebody yes and they jacked it up no
you've never had that happen now then
you're living in a freaking Utopia
that's why you don't understand economy
yet maybe I have undergraduated I know
but that's concerning as well I mean
that probably means I know less never
mind well no not necessarily that just
means you programmed it's a different
story to think in one way because that
disagree with you but that part is true
a lot of it would currently programmed
and then deprogrammed well you got when
you got 13 to one that's a true Monopoly
of professors on the left to the right
that's a pure Monopoly but let me go
back to the question what I'm asking you
asked me the question are you
comfortable you know as long as what
they do with the money that wasn't my
question what was your question my
question was as a general principle yeah
are you okay paying a little more if you
get more same question for Amaya is this
the same thing uh here's why the answer
is no Okay the reason why the answer is
not love your sarcasm the reason why the
answer is no is because if I give
somebody a relative a thousand bucks
okay it's the last thousand dollars
gonna give me I'm telling you bro I'm
gonna pay you back 1500 bucks in two
years yeah never get it back okay two
years later you come back to me hey this
time give me five thousand but I promise
you I'm gonna fix I'm gonna give it back
10 grand yeah okay no here you go two
years later he comes back up dude this
time I'm asking for 10 but I'm changed
right I'm good bro trust me give you the
money yeah I'm gonna fix it
if you give it the third time you're an
idiot in my eyes we keep giving money to
people with zero accountability and we
just keep saying here he goes what are
you talking about 1.9 trillion dollars
but you know for what programs any
programs any programs that were given
money to that there's no accountability
for which is being wasted any one of
them military include any of the
entitlement programs that we have like
include welfare include food stamps
include any one of them would you pull
it up and I'll tell you right now any
one of them what I don't understand is
what do you mean by there's no
accountability can I give an example
please because I think what you're
trying to say is that you don't know
where I'm going with this is an issue
well because so so what you're saying is
you know exactly what happens with the
money when you give it to when you pay
taxes no I just don't understand what
you're talking about you really don't
know what I'm talking about let me give
you something can I just give one
example and then we can open this up and
you guys can have fun doing what you're
doing what I think you are saying is
fool me once shame on you fool me twice
shame on me and I think what Patrick is
alluding to is the fact that we are now
at 30 trillion dollars in debt okay and
the fact that we keep want to pile keep
piling on this issue of like I get it we
all need military we need the police we
need the firemen we need all these
social systems we need a social safety
now we need welfare we need Medicaid we
need Medicare I think what his point is
is like at what point is enough enough
now we want to pile more stuff into our
storage unit that is already filled to
the brim and we need to keep piling and
filing and piling more and at one point
is he saying can we stop funding the
government this way because it's not
it's not a good look for us because
we're at 31 32 35 trillion and what he's
saying I think is like we're gonna have
to make some cuts and make some
adjustments okay and you're saying let's
double down let's let's let's keep
adding some of this I didn't say that no
I'm just I'm like you want to add more
systems you said I I think you said I
want one or two more no but wait a
minute you really didn't understand what
I just said did he not understand it
before China I'm asking you did I want
to get to just a very specific example
of a specific program that you're
displeased with
buddy anything so you're against all
government programs I didn't tell you
all government programs so which ones
are you against if you if you if you
give money into programs that you're
coming out saying hey we're going to
spend 88 million dollars for this okay
if you want me to pull it up and we can
go through expenses and tell you which
ones works and which one doesn't we can
do that as well if that's what you want
to do uh but if you constantly come to
me for more money
let me just put it to you this way yeah
what does it mean when a company or an
individual is in debt two hundred
thousand dollars when a company or when
an individual okay let's just say I'm in
the 200 000 okay
and it was a hundred thousand dollars
five years ago okay
it was fifty thousand dollars ten years
ago yeah it was ten thousand hours
fifteen years ago
I come to you for another fifty thousand
dollars should you lend it to me
probably not no what are we doing
what are we doing we're Landing it
sounds like your analysis but we're
lending our taxpayer money and we keep
getting getting into more and more and
more and more in debt if the government
was an individual or a corporation
I don't understand why investors keep
giving this government more money when
they have no cash the critical answer is
the government and countries are not
like households or companies that's the
difference it's just it's not an energy
that's not true not analogous that's not
true that's not true though so meaning
it's okay for us to keep going into debt
that's okay that's that's not what I'm
saying so what is different important to
have a balanced view that when it comes
to and what's crazy about this is I'm
not advocating for getting more and more
into debt right Trump did a great job of
it blowing up the deficit the deficit we
still have a positive deficit
Republican or Democratic
presidents generally speaking increases
but first make the argument on how
different it is to to give the analogy
yes of personal household that it's okay
for the government to increase its debt
but not on the personal side
it's okay it's not it's not the same and
what I'm struggling with Patrick is that
like everything I'm saying is just being
relayed to me usually interrupting me
incorrectly so now I'm having to clean
up what you think I said to then answer
the original thing my point is you said
those three are different things they
are different explain why they are
different things explain with a
household or corporate
budget or debt you at some point at the
end of the day don't have any more
recourse to carry the debt and you
either have to declare bankruptcy or you
have to all the things that you you you
know with a country of course if the
economic growth becomes decoupled from
the growth in the national debt that is
a problem we've seen it in many many
countries but in the United States and
again I'm not saying who cares about the
desert or the deficit but I think we
have to appreciate that there's a
difference if your economy keeps growing
if that national debt grows more or less
in parallel with the growth of the
economy yeah and it continues to be
backed you don't get to that day where
there is the you're now being evicted
crisis that an individual has that
doesn't mean I want to let me say this
one more time I'm not saying the debt
doesn't matter there are people who say
it literally I'm not saying here's the
question okay so let me let me kind of
try to give the point of uh uh the
example I want to give to you yeah so
what is a sign when an institution keeps
increasing its debt what sign is there
so if I keep getting fatter
is it because I'm a big bone person or
it's because I may have a bad diet and
not exercise and what do you think uh I
guess it I forgot you personally I guess
I'd have to ask your doctor if you
you're a small uh bone guy you don't
seem like you're you were big when you
were have you ever been 200 pounds no
okay now so if you all of a sudden next
time you come on the podcast you're 250
pounds you should be concerned so can
you accidentally become 250 pounds uh
accident it would be a number of
accidents in a row exactly which by the
way you probably enjoyed your dinner you
probably enjoyed your food right but if
you came back 250 pounds yeah as a
friend or even somebody that's in the
similar space that we're creating
content right should I off camera say
hey bro what's up I would appreciate it
if you do okay I should do your father
you got a kid I'd like you to be around
for your daughter thank you
statistically or better society when we
are right okay so if you
come to me and I'm smelling bad I'm not
shaving I love it I have nothing and I'm
getting worse week after week after week
should you question and say Pat is that
then okay I think so yeah I think it's a
good idea these are fun examples I'm
trying to have fun with you different
but no it's not talking about if a
country yeah keeps increasing its debt
yeah year after year after year after
year after year right should we not be
concerned we should be concerned about
whether we're spending money in the
right ways we should be concerned about
whether but let's give them another 1.9
trillion dollars we're saying that
that's the thing you know I I don't but
you are saying that because you said the
only difference when you went to your uh
example of military yeah and you wanted
me to say yes and you said look every
I'm not a socialist because I think this
and he said the only difference is I
just want two or three more programs and
what I'm saying is we can't afford it
today okay maybe in 20 years but do you
are and and I I worry that I don't know
if you think I'm talking and back bad
faith or if you maybe don't understand
my political views but I think
differences that are actually much more
subtle than you think they are are being
blown up as if there's this crazy
difference here about what's going on
we're definitely using different
rhetoric in this conversation but I
don't I don't know whether we're
actually understanding each other really
that well because I'm with you if there
are programs that are wasteful how do we
Define wasteful right that's that's the
difficulty but if there are programs
that are wasteful if there are programs
that are not economically stimulative if
there are programs that are uh being
used for fraudulent reasons or or
whatever the case I'm going to be right
there with you saying we need to do
something about this the the things I'm
looking at when they are done in other
countries yeah the country doesn't
become socialist you can still own your
business they don't socialize your
business they don't they don't communize
your business none of those things
happen many of these countries have
really good business and environment but
they're just saying hey we have enough
riches here that this capitalist system
has created which I'm in favor of where
we can do a couple more things what I'm
saying to you is you don't want it no
it's not what I'm saying to you that I
don't want it yeah
if I if you can stop interrupting this
entire damn show that is freaking you
know it's not fun is it God I'm used I'm
good with it it's part of a uh having
conversations with people who doesn't
offend me but uh if if I sit there and I
say yeah David we can't afford it right
now okay I would say what do you mean I
would tell you it's called 31 trillion
dollars okay is what it's called we're
in debt a lot of debt okay and you may
not have to pay it back somebody has to
pay it back your seven-year-old's gonna
have to pay back but that money's not
going to print a month seven month old's
gonna have to pay back someone's gonna
pay it back okay that 31 trillion
dollars you're not just one they're
going to say guys let's just write this
thing off you guys okay China hey Japan
you cool just write this thing off and
just forget about it and let's start
again yeah how cool would that be we
can't do that we have that we can't
afford it right now one of the things
about a lot of these issues is first of
all they're way bigger than any
conversation where we just like list the
programs and say we cut if you look
historically countries don't cut their
way to economic Prosperity countries
tend to grow their way to economic
Prosperity you with me so far yes come
countries grow their way out of economic
Prosperity no that's the opposite of
what I said come countries grow their
way into economic Prosperity they grow
by building one too many times so let's
keep getting into debt is what you're
saying no that's not what I'm saying so
what are you saying what I'm saying is
over the long term if the government
spending is economically stimulative it
will help to grow the economy it's
fundamental demand side economic so like
as an example there are certain
government programs that are highly are
these cigars by the way I just noticed
this over here you can take it um if
countries uh
spend money on Pro I I don't know you
seem to be looking something up I don't
know if you're paying I'm listening so I
am listening to you go ahead if
countries spend money on economically
stimulative programs yeah the high
economic multiplier they can create
growth if countries spend money in ways
that are not economically stimulative
then it increases the debt so for
example just to pick two different
programs I don't have any emotional
attachment to these two programs I'm
just going to list two programs food
stamps and what is happening in here by
the way or are those gummies yeah taking
vitamins man this is this is healthy for
you I know I don't want to be the 400
pound guy food stamps have a high
economic multiplier okay tax cuts for
the very rich have a low economic
multiplier I'm not passing any judgment
in any way I'm just telling you there
are ways that the government can spend
money that is good for the economy and
ways that is not so good that's my only
point
what were the two programs you said you
wanted to add on I think we should have
some kind of minimum Level Health Care
system for everybody and it would it
would actually be cheaper than what we
have what we have includes people that
go to the emergency room as primary care
which is insanely expensive sometimes
they don't pay their bills and that
leads to everybody who does have health
insurance it's just absorbing that cost
it would just be cheaper if we provided
everybody some basic level of care there
are states that have done it I think
that's just a basic thing
um and secondly I would like to
socialize some aspect of paid
um uh family leave
parental and and maternal not hugely
expensive it's economically at least
stimulative in the sense that when other
countries have done it they find that
productivity ends up being higher when
parents return to work and you know it's
been been widely studied these are just
like two two things we're already paying
for most of them either in terms of
productivity losses or through the
health care that we pay afford to absorb
people who don't pay and use the
emergency room it can be done you know
Revenue neutral what what percentage
like if going back to it with what we
have right now the way it is today yeah
what percentage of your dollar are you
comfortable paying in taxes one percent
really less than Abe Lincoln imposed no
listen I'm not I'm not going this has
nothing to do what I'm telling you yeah
no hold up a different story
um well what percent are you willing to
pay today I am not a high Tax Guy okay
tax High tax I mean listen
um I don't want to get too much into my
my personal finances but like I don't
like I'm not auditing you bro I don't
like this simple question I don't like
that close to half of my income is going
to tax you don't like it I think it's
too high so what do you think is
reasonable oh man Does it include Health
Care in college or not
I I would love to be in the you know 31
total just so you know we're on the same
page there yeah okay so for me the
difference is the following yeah uh uh
one time I'm doing a podcast uh I don't
know who I'm doing a podcast with
anyways this was like a year and a half
ago sounds explosive and then no it
wasn't actually you know you know what I
like about podcasts like this yeah it
makes me go uh research a topic you know
so one time we did a podcast about taxes
and you know how taxes at one point
ninety percent you know it was a 90
taxes and it was like for a long time
Hollywood was this is what they're doing
this is what it was like so you're
talking about a 90 marginal on the very
top incomes Under Ice correct and I make
my point without you freaking intellect
with degrees to interrupt freaking high
school graduate that's ad hominem okay
all right so let me go back to this with
these two Jews bullying me right now uh
so so so we're talking about taxes yeah
okay so I said let me go find out what's
going on with taxes here in the history
of it okay so we send our research team
and I said send me anything yet on taxes
you can assume this was like a very
exciting uh two weeks of my life just
studying taxes it was awesome great
experience I can only imagine what it's
like to want to be an accountant it's
got to be like a you know fascinating
experience High suicide accountancy do
you know what happened to you know the
one data that came about on when taxes
got started the history of tax you know
the whole story yeah it is all this I'm
not going through that part but I want
honor to find out because a lot of
people on the left say you can't compare
governments to companies to you know
families you can it just might not be
useful but meaning it's not the same
thing you can do that financially all
this other stuff yeah so you see the
Lincoln thing that you know story pops
up where you know back in 1861 this guy
goes up and says hey us we kind of need
some money yeah this war was so
expensive for us we're gonna have to tax
everybody six percent yep but I promise
you when we pay it off we'll stop taxes
do you know what happened well after
they paid it off the taxes didn't end no
it ended no they didn't end let me read
this one
so so watch this here okay on August 5th
1861 Lincoln imposed the first federal
income tax by signing the Revenue Act
strap for cash strapped for cash which
the government is kind of like they
don't have cash if they're inset yeah so
they're they need cash just like a
corporation or family we don't have cash
so we need some debt with which to
pursue the Civil War Lincoln and
Congress agreed to impose a three
percent tax on annual incomes over 800
bucks
as early as 1861 Lincoln had began to
take stock of the federal government's
ability to wage war against the South he
sent letters to cabinet members Edward
Bates Gideon Wells and Salman Chase
requesting their opinions as to whether
or not the president had the
Constitutional authority to collect
duties according to documents housed and
interpreted by Library Congress Lincoln
was particularly concerned about
maintaining Federal authority over
collecting revenue from ports along with
along the Southeastern Seaboard which he
worried might fall under the control of
Confederacy the Revenue Act language
okay uh uh according to the U.S treasury
Department the compare comparable
minimum tax income in 20 2003 after
adjustment for inflation would have been
around sixteen thousand dollars Congress
repealed Lincoln's tax law in 1871 which
means there was no more taxes but it
came back up obviously in 1909. so
this is an example of a story where we
need some money let's go to the people
the people say listen here's some money
but I hope this stops it's going to stop
so the moment we allow the government to
use this power too much they've abused
it okay and for me my only argument is
if I have to choose between giving you a
million bucks that's going to sound
crazy okay I hope this doesn't get your
head too big and you get too confident
here please if I give you a million
bucks or if I give a million bucks to
the government I'm willing to bet you're
probably going to create you know a
better climate with a million dollars
and the government would and if I have
the choice to give a million dollars or
billion dollars to creators job creators
small business owners on what they can
do as a source of investment versus
giving that money to the government
government if there was a FICA score if
if there was a FICO score I don't know
what your FICA scores but you know the
range 400 High extremely high 400 to 820
give or take that's the number word set
if we had to give a FICO score to the US
government what do you think their FICO
score would be today yeah but he needs
polls give me the polling on that no
listen here I mean what you're saying is
super interesting I do you know the
point I'm making now
and here's one of the things that that I
think
we I'm guessing we would probably agree
on which is when you think about
um the the way that we organize Society
this isn't politics this is just like
sociology philosophy kind of like
reality once you get a group of people
bigger than about 150 150 people okay if
you want that to be run in some way that
works what we might Define as works you
have to start introducing some level
some level of centralization that
doesn't mean with 150 people you need
the tax system and everything that we
have right now but it's just kind of
like a reality of organizing societies
that as societies grow from 150 people
and think about it 330 million people
now in the U.S 8 billion people in the
country there the idea that you have
which is I'll just pick some people to
give a million bucks to instead of the
government it's that it just doesn't
work that's it that's it that's some
things have to be said I'm having fun
with you buddy when I'm telling you that
but the point I'm trying to make but the
idea is an interesting one no
the point I'm trying to make to you is
that's how the US government was ran
yeah
the country you and I are living in yes
it was ran that way guys we don't have
money we go to the people I promise you
once we pay this off we're going to stop
taxing you yeah and we accepted it you
know no taxation so this we except we're
like totally fine with this we're game
with this and then now it's pure abuse
we don't have a choice now like we did
back then it was ran like a company it
was ran like a family having their
finances in order today America's FICO
score is in the 400s you know in the
400s what you should be able to finance
nothing I don't know 60 down 30 percent
it's at 400 it should be a hundred
percent down but so what what would you
want so you were you you said you were
with me on like low 30s for tax I am
okay yeah so really it sounds like the
issue is more I would I would want a
flat tax and what I'm saying I would
want a flat tax meaning I'd like to go
somewhere between 10 or 15 to 33 and a
time to go to 30 flat is it I get that
but what I'm saying is if America like
right now we need to pay off debt guess
what yeah
attacks me 33. okay but let's gradually
pay some of this stuff off I would like
for them to say we're gonna go off a
budget of 25 or 20 the 13 every we're
going to pay off the debt okay but
here's a problem yes you know why
they'll never never happen well there's
a lot of reasons I mean I don't know
I'll give you my device Congressman
people will never win uh
agenda if we have no term limits these
guys are going to play whatever games
too you're for term limits are you
kidding oh me too absolutely you kidding
me yeah guys we just found some common
ground with David David term limits on
the agenda my challenge isn't a you know
my challenge is we're giving money to
people that have proven to have no clue
what to do with it and the debt keeps
climbing now when it comes to like
social safety net right can I tell you
my view on this stuff and you tell me if
you agree right I moved to the us as an
immigrant okay
I had the benefit if my parents had to
pay for my initial schooling like if
they had to pay out of pocket for
elementary school or whatever the case
may be they you know my mom wasn't
working at the time my dad was just
starting a job where he didn't make a
lot of money they couldn't have afforded
if that public school said we're gonna
charge you right so I immediately got
the benefit of that
follow along right I got the benefit of
police protection and then eventually
all these different things contracts so
when I started my show intellectual
property so the way I see it is I've
been extraordinarily fortunate to be
able to build my business and get to
where I am thanks to a whole bunch of
things that everybody paid for through
taxes so my view now is I'm all let me
finish up I'm also okay like I recognize
you know I've got these great employees
many of them had Public School
educations and they have certain
protections when it comes to Safety in
the world you should be able to do all
that with no more than 30 percent well
I'm not I'm not even getting to three
but so I feel it's almost like a
patriotic thing where if taxes are
properly set and being spent on the
right things I think now my success
which only exists because of previous
taxpayers through all those programs I
mentioned it should go to help other
people who don't have that's the wrong
mindset in my opinion okay and let me
tell you why things are wrong mindset
because uh okay
you ever had a job have I ever had a job
well yeah no you don't have a job right
now your business owner have you had a
job oh yeah yeah yeah okay do were you
there for five years like did you work
for a company for five years yeah I mean
this is kind of funny but I worked for
the now defunct retailer Circuit City
for five years really yeah selling
extended services they pay very well but
I don't know when you work in the
commission very well in the commission I
got laid off when they went from
commission to hourly yeah the people who
were making too many commissions they
didn't want to pay a salary they laid us
off check this out okay so let me let me
see if what year was it you work in a
Circuit City it ended in 2003 so it
would have been like the era by the way
can you tell everybody how much a good
salesperson at Circuit City was making
well if you remember because I I I'm
willing to say this I worked part-time
because I was like starting College
check this out 30 hours a week and I was
making 75 000. that's insane yeah at
Circuit City yeah okay they realized it
was insane and they're like we're not
paying these people but that's
though that's though because
that's why they went out of business
right the model was working you guys
were doing your car came up dude Best
Buy 37 bucks an hour you're about to
validate my points so check this out
this is a perfect example here the
perfect example is here so for me
you know how you go to a funeral and
everybody's morning and maybe you don't
know the person but you're going because
it's somebody you don't have a role like
it's in law or somebody like that sure
but just depend on everybody's face you
feel it right
so for me when I hear a company going
out of business right breaks my heart
especially company that's been on for a
long time because to start a company
it's a very hard very very hard to start
a company to make it last five past five
years super hard right 10 20 30 years
and then create hundreds if not
thousands of jobs it's not easy to do
somebody and a group of people had to
sacrifice a lot right okay so what
you're saying is the following hear me
out okay so the people who started
Circuit City yeah okay those who start
at Circuit City those who paved the way
before you and they came and they
crushed it and now there's new
management and now because the people
before you paved the way you should
accept lower salary to give back to the
people that paved the way before but
it's not the people before that paved
the way it's the people today that are
running Circuit City you're actually not
giving back to the people that paved the
way you're giving it to the idiots that
are running Circuit City today that's
what's going on in America today meaning
you and I I love America I love I lived
in around 10 years I lived in Germany
two years I was in the military and I
come from a family politically on
complete opposite sites but I love this
place it's an amazing country
my responsibility
on how I can contribute to society isn't
through paying taxes it's through
creating jobs it's through you know when
I pay my taxes I pay a lot of taxes this
year a lot of taxes this year last year
was a lot of taxes I've been paying a
lot of taxes period so but for me when I
pay the taxes and I ask where did that
thing go to okay what happened with that
what are they doing with that if they're
doing such a great job with it why does
the debt keep going higher why are we
you know keep uh not seeing any kind of
return things are still same thing both
of them are not asking to raise more
money oh it's only the left you know the
Democrats that just want to go no that's
not it's it's both of these sides who
are part of the same camp another 1.9
trillion another two trillion another
2.7 trillion I'm not for it okay so all
I'm saying to you is the same way the
Circuit City folks ruined the great job
you had making 75 grand you're working
30 hours a week yep they came the new
management decided to change the
compensation compensation structure that
was working that's the perfect example
of a Circuit City went out of business
same thing that a lot of politicians are
doing today yeah it doesn't seem at all
analogous to me but I love talking about
selling extended service plans so we can
stay on Circuit City if you want but in
all seriousness it doesn't seem
analogous to you it doesn't really seem
oh really so let me ask you a question
why does Circuit City go out of business
well let's see
um I'm thinking back now they went out
of business because when they switched
people from commission to hourly they
got rid of the people that were doing
really well because they didn't want to
pay us the hourly equivalent wow so they
got rid of the entrepreneurs they got
rid of it no so so it's not analogous at
all they got rid of the people that are
self-motivated people got it so that
that is actually the perfect example
because they changed the comp plan they
increased taxes for the people that were
working that's not at all analogous they
didn't increase taxes they just laid me
up at the 75 000 people make 75 000
again after they change account no they
did not at a different job not at a
Circuit City not a Circuit City you're
laughing because you see the points they
left to a different place but then you
got a new job and started making more
money but the point is people this is
why people leave in California I was
just gonna say it's not exactly what's
going on in New York and California
that's the kind of high tax states to
come to low tax states so I mean we can
talk about high and low tax states the
effective tax rate especially if you own
cars and homes in a lot of places ends
up being very close yeah let's get off
of circuits no I don't want to get off
of Circuit City stay on this point
because okay that is the point though
David that's the point but I am I'm
trying to have a different Quest a
conversation sure you are I'm trying but
not because it's a more advantageous
conversation because you're saying it's
not an analogous what I just want to
know from you is I get it with the
company the Circuit City deserves to go
out of business and it was allowed to go
out of business and that was great I'm
with you because they made a terrible
business decision I'm completely with
you what I'm asking you is on a human
level in a country country as rich as
the United States
330 million people all these different
things I'm not saying no one should be
rich I'm not saying taxes should be 60
I'm not saying anything I'm just saying
for the little comparatively that it
would take just to make sure that
there's no hungry kids for example that
little little thing you don't have to go
to the ER when you have a problem you
could isn't that much related to you
isolate this we can go to that stay on
this issue don't digress stay on this
issue by the way just out of curiosity
who's your guy like when you were who do
you look up to what what comedian guy
your style do you look up to I just I
just wrote a name down because you
remind me I don't know you sure you
don't have Heroes you don't have
comedians you like no David you got
someone you like I'm just this guy
doesn't lend money to people he doesn't
lend people their cars and he doesn't
have anybody celebrities
you didn't have anybody you watched like
a Bill Maher guys like that that used to
I like this guy like I'm a big Bill
Maher guy I love Chappelle nope no so I
mean I casually would watch Bill Maher
but I mean are you a Jon Stewart guy are
you a you know I like I would watch
John's here a little bit so let's go
back to Circuit City okay
it was my technique for selling the
service plan yeah do you want to know
that no okay you're staying on Services
it's digressing but we can stay on
circuit but do you know why I'm staying
on this topic no okay let me let me this
this is this is there's a metaphor here
I promise you in the business world yeah
okay when a guy or person leaves a
company yes they leave for a reason in
the sales industry many times they leave
because comp changed okay so what
happens with comp this is what typically
happens with comptour sales people a guy
sits there this is 2003 you said that's
what twenty I believe so holy
you're seven you're making 75 out of 18.
yeah okay so check this out I got in
this you want to really know a crazy
story I was that's why I love Circuit
City Stories I was audited because it
wasn't plausible that I was making that
much and so a guy show a I showed up an
investigator with a with a recorder and
they're like so where exactly did you
make this it was a crazy thing my mom
sat with me my mom sat I was like Mom I
don't know
I know I know a lot about the Circuit
City folks because I recruit a lot of
circuit city folks after that happened
to the insurance industry but but this
is something well here's the part though
because you guys were sick Circuit City
sales training was awesome same was
Bally Total Fitness by the way I'm a
Bally's guy okay so Circuit City is
sitting there and they're saying
who the hell is this Pac-Man guy we're
paying 75 grand you're working 30 hours
a week and he's 18. right he shouldn't
get paid that correct we should only pay
him six bucks an hour yes there's no way
this guy's worth we're overpaying him
some idiot at the top said what we're
overpaying them yeah okay so they came
up with this idea that let's fire these
guys that have charm Charisma sarcastic
witty people like him they're selling
awesome who cares if you make 75 they
flipped it on him yep that happened to
me when I was at your when I was 21 I
just got out of military so people had
Bally's at one point were making 180 200
Grand year in the 80s in the 90s sales
people by the way Circuit City was
paying 180 200 EUR to sales people
Circuit City was killing it was like one
guy making that much well one guy per
place in Connecticut no no no no there
was no one in our store making that much
well maybe not your store but there's a
lot of guys that were making money on
circus if you're 30 years old making 75
there were plenty of guys that were
making money 18 years I'm sorry 18 years
old making 75. a lot of people were
making money doing sales so
here's the point please guy changes to
come yep he lost you okay you get fired
you go elsewhere you do other things yep
did a lot of other people leave
well anybody making under 10 an hour in
commissions was too bad of a salesperson
they got rid of him anybody making over
20 an hour there were two people in our
store I was one of them they got rid of
us so they only kept those 10 to 20. so
they kept them or average why socialism
doesn't work
oh now you want to flip it don't you no
no no you're sure think about that too
socialism would be you've got to keep
the ones around no and actually it's not
socialism
so it's just crazy this is a great
conversation about things completely
disconnected from 100 but I love the
conversation they're 100 connected is
what they are they're 100 connected
because it's like saying if you tax
people less hey wait a minute elon's
making too much money these billionaires
are getting too rich these millionaires
are getting too rich this is not good we
need well tax we need this we need that
no way we should be doing this hey you
know when elon's saying something in uh
in uh whatever was in California and the
mayor responded back and he says okay
noted boom I don't know if you remember
this now do you remember when the the
mayor or yeah
Silicon Valley we should do away with
him he's like all right God we should do
away with test line there this and Elon
is this like and got his tweets back and
says no doubted moves to Austin great
guess what Austin got Elon a lot of
people Florida got a lot of great talent
Texas got a lot of talent people leave
when you change comp planes I'm sitting
here giving you the example of where
taxes are good 33 we're on the same page
okay I'm willing to go 33 you're saying
30 31 which you're a little greedy I got
to tell you well I'm a pretty socialist
this is so this is so uh first of all
come on yeah okay but are you an Elon
fanboy
not as much as your Joe Biden boy Fanboy
no because that you're you're a die hard
I would be interested if I would have
known I would have got you sure oh it's
obvious you you love uh seriously no
what's not now seriously are your
podcast said why do you have a painting
of Biden in the back oh come on okay so
all right okay go ahead what is your
thought because I was a relatively early
Tesla investor and I still drive a Tesla
I think it's gonna be my last one I've
sold the shares are where are you on
Elon because a couple people wrote to me
they're like oh uh Patrick's Fanboy or
on Tesla either okay so
can I take a sip yeah is that an energy
drink now it is owned by Tesla by the
way too yeah
no it's not I don't but by the way while
he's drinking this why are why are you
done with Tesla why is this your last
Tesla the reason are you on not Elon
Musk Fanboy I have no emotional thought
whatever about Elon okay so here was my
thought okay when I got the Tesla shares
in 2015 I thought
Electric's coming early mover range and
charging network are the things that
matter this is gonna set them up they're
gonna it's gonna be crazy
so I bought the shares eventually I got
one of the cars I was like this is
fantastic once you buy shares when when
2015 26 February 2016 I think it was so
I get the car I'm like unbelievable
range fantastic the charging Network all
this stuff the build quality kind of
sucks everything's rattling there's
things that are held together seems to
be by tape but that's okay I like I get
it they haven't been building cars very
long they're gonna it's gonna improve
it's gonna improve got the second Tesla
better build quality still it's the same
issue four times now every time it's
literally something that has to be
ratcheted has to be taken apart now the
other companies that let's be honest
Audi builds better cars than Tesla
they've been doing it for a hundred
years they don't rattle Etc they're
losing the charging network advantage
slowly partially thanks to the inflation
reduction Act and the the high speed
here we go spokesperson for Biden good
and also
um the range there's more and more cars
now that are matching the range so I
think the time that first mover
Advantage is diminishing drive so David
if if somebody didn't know either one of
us yeah and they had to pull yep to to
say who's a Elon Fanboy it would be you
why here's why you're against all of it
can I can I can I answer why are you
such a bully let me answer man uh one
I've never owned the Tesla okay two I
don't own Tesla stock I've never bought
Tesla stock okay okay because I thought
it was always overpriced wow okay
uh but here's what I will tell you
please as a jockey I'm a fan of the
Jockey him being the jockey the business
I thought Tesla too many people who were
Fanboys who thought that it's just
because it's him it's going to kill it
it's down 85 for the year but the point
is it's at the right number right now
it's around the number it should be give
or take maybe it's still not at the
number it needs to be but long if it's a
long investment I think it's a good long
investment I think a lot of people got
killed last year by the way a lot of
people made you know money last year as
well Citadel Ken Griffin made 16 billion
last year you don't make 16 billion
during a flat economy or even slightly
down you make it because you were
shorting certain stocks and some of the
famous stocks to short last year hence
the company and the boy you'll love the
most you know your guy Elon Musk okay
on paper what he's done you're a fanboy
I'm out of the stock and I'm getting out
of the car so you're an ex-fan boy is
what you are
there's nothing wrong with that the
product yeah was had a specific
Advantage never been a ton of the
product I've never been a fan of the
product I've never been one that has
gone my but by the way my best one of my
best friends every time he named it
sunny lawn well that's qualified okay he
owns Teslas
stocks all of it total fan of that stuff
I'm not that camp yeah what I do like is
the following just so you know when you
leave this place you best say thank you
to Elon okay you owe him a thanks okay a
big things have you enjoyed the the
session we've had today together yeah is
this a good day for you yeah I mean
listen I don't know that I think we
talked past each other a lot okay and
things that are not actually
disagreements were zoomed in on and and
I think we would actually get along on
80 of stuff if the conversation was not
for television potentially did you watch
Kyle's uh show when Kyle and I were
together or no I watched some of it okay
you know how much fun I had with Kyle no
it's the same we had a lot of fun with
it I have no idea how much fun by the
way if you told me you are willing to
come back next month you're on next
month I I enjoy the sauce so you don't
one thing you need to know with you you
should I don't look at comments anymore
the comments on this from your audience
are going to be brutal I'm going to need
a new therapist I'm gonna need a new
therapist I actually think I actually
think they like you a lot of as well
trust me and here's why they're with our
audience the reason with our audience is
because we like people like that to come
we don't want like by the way you know
who's going to be on Thursday you ready
for this one I I don't know like the
complete opposite of you yes it's going
to be Ben Shapiro
is it worse James O'Keefe is going to be
on Thursday from uh from uh Veritas oh
my God yeah so he's going to be honest
but if I'm sure you guys would like to
have lunch together and have a good time
together I'll still be here I'll swing
by so but but here's the point here's
the baby we said something the point the
point I want to make too is on on the
topic of differences and all you said he
was going to has to thank Elon for
something yeah because without Elon you
and I wouldn't have tweeted each other
he's running Twitter right now uh
talking about we tweeted each other last
year I know we did but you know again
what does that have to do with Elon it's
a connection we have through Twitter
that he's running now
a year ago it had nothing man I'm giving
this guy credit because it's the bad boy
to find a reason to thank Elon for
something listen I have it let's do an
attitude I'd like to find reasons to be
thankful for people right now who is a
bigger Elon Musk Fanboy no way or
Patrick but but if you want to say like
in an area that I believe in what he's
gonna do as a jockey okay yeah I I
believe in him as a jockey so if if I'm
gonna if I'm on a long anything I'm on a
long what he's gonna be doing investment
by the way I really appreciate the
metaphor that you're using right now
of the horse versus the jockey the horse
in this instance
guys we are finding common grounds
the other analysis is Circuit City you
didn't believe in is is the Circuit City
did have a little analysis
level I think if we don't Dove deeper it
falls come on bro that's like
you dropped like it's as if I wanted to
say it but you said it they got rid of
the top guys on the bottom guys to make
the middle guys happy that's socialism
it's not it's social they do this does
something for the bottoms later saying
he's not a socialist folks he's
defending socialism okay but so the
reality is Circuit City did shut you
know what would be a cool shirt here
would be a cool shirt here's what would
be a cool shirt oh wait for it can you
pull up this book called first-rate
madness pull up the book to cover I have
an idea I have an idea for uh our
Frontier I've got a book that I'm
working on so maybe I I could take this
and this will be the cover let's see I
don't know if you want to use this cover
but it's so it's a so pull up that you
see that cover right there First Rate
Madness yeah part of it is Kennedy okay
yeah part of it is uh uh LinkedIn and
the other one is I don't know who the
bottom left one is could be Jackson
because they talk about him a lot it's
not Sinatra uh are you being sarcastic
no I'm kidding yeah okay no I think we
should get a picture like that mate and
I'll tweet it out today just because I
like you I think it should be half the
face should be Biden okay the other
quarter should be Bernie and the last
quarter should be Elon Musk as a fanboy
for him and I'm gonna say David this art
was create can you by the way can you
tell our graphic design I'm sure he's
going to talk all day today we're
gonna have a good time like that's a
gift for me to you I don't know what
we're talking about but it sounds
interesting yeah what was the name you
wrote down describing David he's John
Stu this guy's talented I like it I like
it you look like Jon Stewart you've
never heard before people say you enjoy
when we're talking about Jews who are 5
[Laughter]
I'm actually not going there at all I'm
purely Talent okay you're the the witty
the the poking the sarcasm the you have
it you have that Talent it's you can't
teach that you either have it you don't
have it you have it I appreciate it you
you really are very pull up a picture of
Jon Snow by the way you you did there is
sort of an uncanny Joseph
all right let's
Young Jon Stewart here is that a new
picture oh that's new that's a monkey
can I get a young boy uh young Jones why
would they put that picture on his
Wikipedia he's gonna have better no when
he was young he was way harder no when
he was young he was way harder okay but
I'm sorry there you go you have a
blonder version there's a little bit
better hair I think but yeah good hair
too okay last we got eight minutes here
wait but so you're you're not that's
Joseph could be a Jewish last name a
Syrian a series a Syrian man like Ben
David
is house bets David got it Ben is son of
and yes I speak I speak Arabic as well
really yeah no you're way more of a
Young Jon Stewart sounds hard to believe
Joseph Gordon hard to believe so for
example when I watch Passion to Christ
yeah I actually cannot understand what
they're saying literally I didn't watch
it and even if I watched it I assure you
I would not have understood it
yeah okay so last thoughts here before
we wrap up we got seven minutes you pick
your topic what do you want to do if you
don't have a topic for you but you you
okay you're in trouble so the scientist
what's gonna happen here what are your
thoughts with yeah do you think it's
gonna be ugly where are you from the
school of thought or there's going to be
a civil war it's already starting you
heard what Trump said yesterday loyalty
I'm about loyalty but so okay give us
your thoughts I do think so I think
Trump is furious there have been reports
for six seven months that
DeSantis should have said I would
consider it if Trump doesn't run and
DeSantis did has not said that and
you're supposed to say that that's the
Loyalty test I do so selfishly in two
ways I hope it's an absolute disaster
one I think it'll make it less likely
either of them win if they have a year
during which they're just going crazy at
each other and number two I think it
would be hilarious because
um honestly either one could end up on
top I know that there's this idea among
some of my colleagues that DeSantis is
similar to Trump but smarter better
spoken less Gaff prone all these things
Trump is really good with the nicknames
and the making fun of people and stuff
if DeSantis declares and they're
actually running a national campaign not
Florida but a national campaign I would
not understate the possibility of trump
really doing the DeSantis what he did to
Little Marco you know calling Ted Cruz's
wife ugly this sort of stuff it could
get ugly and it's not clear to Santa's
will get the best of it
yeah I I don't know if I disagree it's
it's a
okay so here's a question for you you're
on the inside uh strategy team for Trump
you're on the inside strategy team for
the santis yeah what are you telling
that I know but I know you're gonna say
Trump's not gonna do anything you say
anyway but what are you saying what
would you say is a strategy for if
you're like hey to win we got to do XYZ
what would you I think I I have I am
terrible on political strategy but one
of the if I if I had been advising Trump
I would have said don't announce in
November five days after a midterm
election I would I would not have done
that if I'm DeSantis team I would say
listen you're not even running and in
some polls you're defeating Trump I
would wait continue to allow Trump to be
furious continue to allow Trump to he
had this low energy rally in South
Carolina nobody went he's sweating and
it was bright orange it was just
horrible keep letting Trump do this
stuff where he just looks silly and then
when you finally do announce really
think about it and do it in a way where
you actually launch a formidable
campaign instead of jumping in now and
getting involved in this stuff I
wouldn't do it
very interesting feedback okay uh
question uh uh do you have a book you're
promoting is there anything you're
promoting it's being written still so I
don't have it to promote so what would
you like us to drive to your YouTube
channel or Twitter love it if people
Twitter oh God no I would love it if
people went to my YouTube channel Okay
And subscribe can we put the link in it
put the link in chat description all of
it
uh and David you have to know I can't
wait to have you the next time around I
can't wait to have a different kind of
conversation because I think the next
one's going to be better than this one
because now we kind of have an idea now
we know each other and I can come
prepared we can talk energy drinks
cigars and supplements
yesterday we're like so what are we
going to talk about tomorrow so listen
this guy's an expert on private Equity
we're going to talk Venture Capital yep
and we're talking GPT it's what we're
going to talk about with them it's like
what are you talking about this guy's
not that guy I said anyway all the other
David Pacman no I'm talking about you
we're joking about it yesterday because
there is there another division yeah
yeah I know I know there is I know there
is well we must uh take him down did you
think
yeah I've been in bed okay no in
conferences and I'm like I know you're
looking
I don't know if you're joking right now
but we're gonna spend two hours talking
about politics Trump socialism Bernie
Biden yeah and I I was proven correct
yes you were by the way shout out to
Circuit City for making it the man you
are today thank you yeah no in all
seriousness I talk with my Circuit City
colleagues it threw me at age 16 when I
started 15 into a situation where people
would come in all sorts of different
types of people I immediately have to
build rapport I immediately have to
figure out how to build a relationship
get him to trust me Etc how to talk
think on my feet it was invaluable even
in what I'm doing today it was just an
unbelievable thing and it ended sadly
with as we know they fired the top
people well gang if you enjoyed today's
podcast and you want us to bring our
buddy here back give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel uh and uh share
this I think the audience wins today
then when there's banter there's
disagreements there's arguments you know
you sit there you're like I like what he
said I agree with him Pat got this wrong
he got the strong whatever you win you
got the argument we just had a
conversation together we're all winners
have a great day everybody we'll do this
again on Thursday you're all winners
like he said all winners whether you're
at the bottom the top or the middle yeah
you're all winners take care bye-bye
exactly